hello
can you see me can you hear me over this
massive cardboard box so this is super
exciting as you guys know i
love video games and halo infinite as
officially launched and we've got a
couple little care packages here so on
my amazon alexa it tells me whenever
like i have a shipment and i got this
little notification it popped up it said
your paper towel has been delivered i
open this up
and i see this
classified and i realized oh no no we
need to take this and immediately do an
unboxing so
we're gonna do just that
gosh i'm so excited this is also a super
exciting box
what else do we have in here does this
all come out yes it does
gosh this is a cool box
oh
this is so cool okay before i open this
i need to un
do this the classified documents
oh my gosh
look at this this is so cool it's a
little lanyard with my name on it dude
oh
that's me and my little gamer tag oh
shoot oh freaking wow oh my gosh ah i
haven't even opened the box yet and this
is
battle pass either the enemy
united nations space command officials
has satisfactorily confirmed your
security clearance and identity please
examine and secure your personalized
unsc mission equipment you have a high
clearance id badge oh my gosh i do
what's in here
oh
the keys um okay so i guess it wasn't
actually locked so
uh the security clearance has been
breached
know your weapon
dude this is
a really
cool
little kit i hope i have a little
lanyard for this i'm gonna wear this
around the house and just be like
security clearance level um
high
high clearance so you guys may have seen
the video i did an unboxing of the halo
infinite special edition xbox i did end
up buying that off of a friend so um no
i didn't buy that off of a stranger in
the street out of a trunk of a car i
mean technically was in the trunk of his
car
but it wasn't as shady of a dealing as
it may have looked on tick tock clearly
i have hacked the system since this is
already unlocked celebrating 20 years
it's so crazy thinking that halo was 20
because i actually remember in college
the first time seeing people play halo
and i was like what are you guys playing
can i please play and they let me and at
this time during early college times i
was kind of back into pc gaming i had
made my own pc we would have lan parties
and i was playing unreal tournament and
quake three that was like my go-to we
also did play a little bit of
counter-strike but um yeah once i kind
of like played halo on console i was
like she's back we're back to console
again wait should i open this in the
order of the numbers okay we're gonna do
that
number one
first
oh
oh my gosh it's a little jacket oh this
is nice
wow
number two
oh my gosh
no
freaking
way i was just about to spend a lot of
money
on ebay to get this controller
this is the elite halo infinite edition
controller this thing looks so beautiful
and i was kicking myself for not
reordering it but look
oh my god it's so beautiful
holy
moly look at this beautiful
braided cable
wow the attention to detail
let's check oh my god this is beautiful
once you've played with an elite
controller it is so hard to go back to a
regular one
the detail is what really really gets me
so excited i'm so excited i cannot wait
to play halo i'm so hyped because
obviously like i love the holidays i get
to spend time with my family but there's
also a lot of down time like people
actually do take vacations during the
holidays so my holiday vacations are
normally playing video games so i cannot
wait to catch up
what are you is this there something
else in here oh the freaking game i've
been playing a lot of the multiplayer i
was at my sister's house and we stayed
up so late playing halo when it actually
felt like college again so my sister had
one her husband had one my sister jenna
that is and we were playing with some of
our friends online and it actually felt
like college house what else we got
we've got number three
it's a freaking master chief helmet
get out of here
oh my god it's playing music
what
oh god
can i put this on my head
i think i can put this on my head
so i'm inside the helmet now
i can't really see very well i'm pretty
sure that if i got caught in combat
with this helmet on
uh i probably would not
it would not survive
wow
it's just like a little stand for it
dude this is really cool you
have found a home here okay we've got
helmet we've got controller we've got
the keys to the jeep we've got our high
clearance security badge what could
possibly be next
moving on to this box
so i had no idea what was in this one
but i do know what is in this i'm just
gonna open it up because i'm so excited
there clearly is some labels on here
that says handle with care because
careful handling needs to be in place
for what is inside this
for me oh my gosh i can't i actually
can't believe this this is gonna be so
great as a halo fan
and also a fan of shiny things
oh my gosh there's so much packaging in
here
oh
oh it's beautiful
i just want to say i've run out of floor
space i've done several unboxings today
and i no longer have a floor so this is
a swarovski and halo collaboration and
in my note it is saying that if i
publicly speak about this product i have
not received any compensation but they
have sent me this to check out they have
provided me these products for review
but the opinions are my own all i know
is my opinion is i'm excited about this
dude i saw these online and i honestly i
almost started crying because they're so
beautiful i love collectibles and i
especially love collectibles when they
are shiny
and shimmering and splendid and oh boy
check this out
oh my god even the box is incredible
like it's a nice green halo infinite
theme we're zooming in for this action
sorry controller you need to exit frame
[Music]
i actually
am slightly getting a little bit
teary-eyed i'm not sure if you can see
it but these are so
freaking beautiful oh my god i love
swarovski i think all of their stuff is
so beautiful and they've done some
really cool collaborations lately
this is absolutely
stunning it has taken my breath away
oh my god
this is number 12
of 117 i know i get a little dramatic
sometimes this is no way am i at all
acting right now like this is seriously
just an absolute beautiful piece of art
like look at this
oh my god i'm so
freaking excited and look at the energy
sword
oh my gosh
this
is so perfect like i actually can't
believe it is there a little stand oh my
god there's a stand for it
i can't believe it i
can you guys believe this beauty i need
to find like a very special home for
this in my house like this is seriously
this might be like one of my favorite
things
that i've ever received i'm saving this
box
this is beautiful like absolutely
everything about this is so perfect like
this is so beautiful
okay that's really sharp i see why they
put the uh little protection on there
this is amazing these are so beautiful
and i'm gonna put a link in the
description if you guys want to get more
information about how you can get these
there's actually a charity happening on
stockx so if you guys are interested you
guys can check that out these are a
limited edition item there are only 117
of them with the iconic spartan number
for master chief and i'm so excited i
have actually downloaded the campaign
and i will be playing this week and i
cannot wait and with that i will see you
guys in my next video i hope you um
i hope you have a good day
i've been trying to come up with a
different way to end my videos and
it's clearly it's not it's not going so
well
[Music]
you